silly string that bright fun party in an
aerosol can was actually invented by
mistake
believe it or not it was supposed to
help heal your broken bones
[Music]
in 1972 leonard a fish an inventor and
robert p cox a chemist were granted a
u.s patent for a foamable resinous
composition
the two initially set out to create an
aerosol can that could spray an instant
cast on a broken leg or arm and the
invention worked but when it came to
packaging their discovery they tested
500 different types of nozzles through
their tests fish came upon one that
produced a string a string that shot 30
feet across the room inspired they
decided to turn their instant cast into
a toy
after altering the formula to produce a
more colorful less sticky string the
pair set out to market their product
neither of them knew the first thing
about selling toys so they made an
appointment with wamo in california
but the meeting didn't go exactly as
planned
fishing cox sprayed the string all over
the office including on the person they
were meeting with
and unsurprisingly get out they were
asked to leave the premises just one day
later fish received a telegram from wemo
asking him to send 24 cans for a market
test
turns out that a trace of the silly
string was left on a lampshade in the
office and was later spotted by wemos
owners who themselves demanded a market
test immediately
[Music]
two weeks later guamo signed a contract
to license the product now known as
silly string
[Music]